son palais
du petit bois dormant je joue de la
fuite une fois
j'ai put et on continue comme ça
[Musique]
le fou notre monde si squeeze et avec
délai coup ça fait toujours un petit il
en plus
non sans rire alors en fait pourquoi je
fais cette petite vidéo parce que pour
ceux qui ne savent pas on a été invité
aux chaumes room de edel c dans paris
donc moi y'a veille avec roxy avec jojo
il y avait souhaité que jordan divx et
c'est un peu comme la dernière fois
qu'on a testé medal of honor sauf que
cette fois on a testé need for speed
most wanted
alors je vais vous dire c'est un jeu que
j'attendais parce que bon dans l'aîné de
forcefield à selena forspeed ya eu des
hauts et des bas et honnêtement pour moi
me suicider le meilleur need for speed
parce qu'on peut bien tu n'es sa voiture
yann l'exploration il ya tout et c'est
enfin ya toutes ces choses là qui font
c'était pour moi le meilleur des deux
forces pid la liste noire et tout et
puis bon honnêtement j'étais j'étais
tellement heureux quand ils ont annoncé
qu'ils ont ressortir et mais j'étais
sceptique et ce qu'ils ressortent un jeu
qui a bien marché histoire de faire un
nouveau emmené de force l'idée de le
vendre genre ouais bon il a le même nom
les gens vont se dire qu'il est aussi
bien que le 1er voilà prologue génial
écoutez franchement j'ai testé et je
peux vous dire qu'elle s'y palka ladies
and gentlemen parce qu'ils les nord
non sans rire c'est à dire qu'en fait il
reprend les mêmes principes dont j'ai
vous présentez vaguement mes impressions
tu as ensuite on analysera un petit peu
plus les détails dans ce cas nouveau ce
qu'être pareil
et puis ensuite on verra un petit peu le
mode multi qui est tout simplement
génial c'était le sommaire du jour
bon donc en fait ce qui est génial c'est
ya le mode exploration libre donc comme
dans le premier du nom
bon ben c'est qu'ils ont joué sur
gamecube ou sur ps2 est sorti en 2005
2004 2005 quoi vous pouvez vous souvenir
qu'en fait j'avais ce mode exploration
libre donc on pouvait faire ce qu'on
voulait dans la ville y avait des
barrières à nancy c'est un bernotat
redon y'a bon bref en gros on se bat et
des dans l'avion c'est un type de ce
qu'on voulait et puis en fait moi
j'avais vachement accroché à ce système
là parce que c'était un petit peu
nouveau à cette époque si bon évidemment
dans ce nouvel soutenu bruno ressorte
dans ce nouveau need for speed most
wanted
on retrouve ça le mode exploration libre
mais on retrouve aussi des petits des
petits suppléments et des petites des
petites choses qui ont été enlevés alors
au niveau des suppléments on retrouve le
menu easy drive donc je vais vous mettre
tout de suite une séquence où je me sers
de ce fameux menu tu me voyait en haut à
gauche c'est à dire qu'est ce que c'est
que venise alors qu'ils y drive mais moi
je vais gagner aujourd'hui
alors en fait le menu des drags c'est un
petit menu qui vous permettra d'accéder
en fait aux courses donc c'est à dire
que d'enlever dans le jeu il y a en tout
40 véhicules on vire on verra juste
après comment les débloquer et chaque
véhicule possède quatre ou cinq courses
qui sont propres véhicules
c'est à dire que gagner douze mille fois
par course il faut que vous avez fait
les quatre ou cinq courts du véhicule
les courses vous font gagner que 500
points si vous mettez votre corps donc
ça sert à rien autant changer de bagnole
et bien vous accédez à ses courses dans
le menuisier drive donc vous saisissez
la course et ça et ça vous mettra donc
sur votre gps donc bon dans le jeu
évidemment une game le chemin à suivre
pour arriver jusqu'à la course et une
fois que vous aurez fait cette course je
l'aurais déjà fait dans l'inédit drive
vous pourrez directement lancé la course
sans avoir à vous déplacer si vous êtes
à 6 km par exemple tout de suite ob vous
pouvez entendre vous trouvez dans la
course mais vous gagnerez bien moins
deux points puisque vous l'aurait déjà
fait donc dans ce menu hydrive on peut
aussi retrouver la personnalisation de
la voiture donc ce qu'ils perdent par
contre niveau qu'est ce que j'appelle
une personnalisation c'est le tuning
mais pas du tuning au niveau de
l'apparence mais uniquement le tuning au
niveau des performances c'est à dire
aller de la transmission
nitro le parfum de pare chocs
oui si parce que ça peut être
aérodynamique pour aller plus vite ou
alors un gros machin pour faire des gros
textes etc
et puis voilà donc dans ce milieu on a
accès à un petit peu aux fonctionnalités
du jeu donc sans avoir besoin à faire
star toi aller dans la planque comme
comme il fallait faire dans need for
speed most wanted premier du nom naveen
plan qu'il fallait y aller balade on a
un accès direct à tous à aller zeus
menuiserie drague et on peut aussi
choisir notre voiture directement dedans
avec une voiture qu'on aura trouvée en
fait pas ce qu'on veut je viens juste ap
on peut tout de suite changé de voiture
et se retrouvait dans une nouvelle
voiture sans avoir à aller au garage
donc par exemple je roule l'aop d'un
coup j'ai envie de changer je choisis et
hop je change de voiture et au même
endroit n'y a pas de souci ça mais deux
secondes virgule 318 centièmes donc au
niveau des voitures il ya quarante
véhicules même plus de ça c'est une
visite surprise et en fait ce qui est
génial c'est que ces voitures vous aller
les trouver dans le jeu
donc en fait vous balader en jeu et à
des endroits plus ou moins cachés autant
retrait ou quoi vous trouverez les
véhicules donc vous vous approchez du
véhicule il suffit de faire y
pour le trouver pour le prendre part
dont tout simplement bon évidemment le
véhicule que vous aurez laissé à la
place de celui là et va il sera dans
votre menu la easy drive où il ya toutes
les bagnoles et ben avait évidemment
vous pourrez si vous avez envie de
reprendre ce que vous avez avant le
choisir dans ce menu vous perdez pas
votre voiture et heureusement parce que
parfois on trouve des voitures bien nul
m vous verrez par vous même enfin bon
voilà c'est un petit peu son niveau du
système de jeu exploration libre
découverte de voiture le menu
il hydrate qui facilite un peu le jeu et
puis aussi ce net for speed most wanted
a été fait avec les créateurs de brno
dont qui ressemble énormément à burnout
paradise surtout au niveau des techdays
qui joue trouve sur un petit peu cheap
et parfois on frôle injuste la voiture
suffit qu'elles sont un petit peu moins
bien au niveau des stades dans le poids
et dans la la force un peu de la bagnole
et puis vous faites ou foot et intégra
on alors vous avez à peine effleuré la
voiture ça des fois c'est un peu chiant
mais à part ça oui c'est vrai qu'au
niveau de la maniabilité de l'impression
de vitesse c'est plus du born que d'une
et for speed et honnêtement c'est pas
plus mal ça c'était un [ __ ] de mix en
mode saas est énorme c'est un peu le
bordel en fait tout simplement avec du
fun mais faut quand même gérer la
maniabilité niveau de la maniabilité
c'est un bon compromis entre paradise et
most wanted parce que dans paradise la
maniabilité je trouve elle est quand
même assez simple oui je l'avais jamais
bien signé par abel elle est quand même
assez simple on tombe facilement et
c'est alors classé dépend vraiment mais
si vous avez une voiture plus lourds ou
vraiment toutes légères et chaque
voiture a son propre style de jeu quand
vous changez de voitures formant
s'habituer à la conduite de cette
nouvelle voiture a son propre style de
jeu sa propre apparence et
malheureusement parlant d'apparence
quand je vous disais tout à l'heure on
pouvait personnalisés au niveau des
performances tuner les performances de
sa voiture
on peut pas le faire au niveau de
l'apparence c'est dommage on peut
changer la couleur uniquement en passant
dans des stations qui répare votre
voiture ça change la couleur mais on
peut pas ouais voilà modifier les jantes
le modèle émettre des néons je sais pas
trop quoi on peut passer pas disponible
et c'est dommage parce que c'était une
fonction que j'adorais dans notre for
speed most wanted de 2004 2005 juste
plus la bête
donc je suis un petit peu dégoûté pour
ça enfin bon alors dans le mode solo
vous allez retrouver éventuellement
évidemment pardon cette bonne vieille
liste noire dont je crois que je
pour combien il en a cette fois ci je
vais pas dire de bêtises je vais rien
vous dire mais ça doit être 15 me semble
dit je sais plus donc en fait donc c'est
tout comme dans le premier volet on
voulait faire des courses de base n'est
en mesure d pour ce type normal donc ça
peut être soit des courses rapides
soient faux passé soit une poursuite
avec les flics enfin il ya plusieurs
types de courses pour vous si vous
croyez vous découvrir c'est juste énorme
et c'est des types de courses bien fun
je me souviens plus dans le solo les
types de courses me souviens du multi
quoi qu'il en soit après avoir fait un
certain nombre de courses à la fin de
chaque course vous gagnez dsp et csp
vous ps vous c'est plutôt risqué me
semble pour bref en fait ces deux points
les plus vous avez de points ça
fonctionne par paliers dès que vous
atteignez un palier de débloquer de
course bascule et une consommation en
chine c'est une course contre l'un de
deux conducteurs de cette fameuse liste
noire pour retrouver dans premier du nom
et ça franchement ça fait plaisir parce
que c'est des courses spéciales qui sont
bien meilleurs que les pontes de base
qui sont bien plus genre je vais te
défoncer je vais défoncer c'est un peu
le dawa et ccim vachement marrant
et puis bah ça fait plaisir de retrouver
cette petite liste non parce que c'est
ce qui motive mais bon malheureusement
dans cette france là il n'y a pas de
reproche mans là je vous cache pas je
suis vraiment trop heureux de vous faire
cette vidéo parce que j'avais geek et le
premier relais finit au moins huit fois
et y avait cette petite histoire où vous
arrivez dans la ville il ya la file qui
vous dit il faut que tu fasses il faut
que tu passes à machin le jeu terminé
par la poursuite avec nos pics et
c'était génial parce que ces petites
histoires vont plonger un peu plus dans
le jeu malheureusement là il n'y a pas
vraiment de l'histoire même pas du tout
donc c'est un petit peu dommage c'est
juste des courses à l'état brut voilà on
veut progresser et c'est un petit peu
bête
enfin c'est pas bête mais c'est s'enlève
ce petit côté du jeu que je kiffe l
histoire mes mots bon je vais pas vous
mentir on peut s'en passer et au niveau
des graphismes c'est juste
pas comparable d'ailleurs je vous dis
pas comparable c'est vraiment pas
comparables assez c'est quoi bon je sais
plus le nom de second développé mais en
tout cas les graphismes ils déboitent
par exemple à ceux femmes ce superbe
pied quand vous sortez d'un tunnel du
soleil qui défonce les yeux comme dans
la vraie vie qu'on ne voyait plus trop
la route donc c'est un camion qui arrive
de face vous le prenez j'adore du coup
dès qu'il sort d'un tunnel tu fais
perdre tu poses des baux en fermant les
yeux donc généralement ça ne passe pas
enfin bon voilà au niveau du multijoueur
puisque oui le multijoueur est très très
très très très intéressant dans ses
dépenses privées alors on a pu le tester
on était 14h15 quand on a pu tester et
c'était un plaisir mais vraiment alors
on fait comment ça marche
eh bien vous rejoignez tout simplement
la partie d'un ami donc vous êtes en
mode exploration à plusieurs vous pouvez
aller jusqu'à je peux jusqu'à combien
mais en tout cas on était quinze donc
c'est quand même un sacré nombre
et vous vous êtes dans le mode
multijoueur voilà vous êtes dans la dans
la partie de votre ami en mode
exploration donc tous vos amis peuvent
vous de joindre un quand vous voulez
mais bon faut débloquer la partie si
vous voulez être tranquille est ce qu'il
va se passer c'est qu'il va y avoir un
point de rendez vous fixé et vous une
fois que vous
une fois que vous allez pardon en groupe
à ce point de rendez vous vous attendez
donc dès que tout les joueurs sont
passés dans point de rendez vous il se
trouve que il y à un mode de jeu qui va
se lancer
donc en fait le led pouvant mettre de la
partie entre guillemets aura mis au
point un cycle constitué de cinq
épreuves donc ça peut être des causes
d'autres trucs femme que je vais vous
dire juste après et une fois que vous
êtes à ce point de rendez-vous le cycle
se lancer la première épreuve qui
commence alors honnêtement la transition
entre les deux est super marrant de voir
à l'écran ça commence direct vers vous
comme ça hop c'est parti allez hop on y
va donc j'en ai qui gruge un peu et qui
prennent par exemple de la vence du clae
chemin est déjà tracée sur le gps on
sait déjà dans quelle direction aller
alors qui a encore des cons et est donc
c'est parti hop ça commence on fonce
et honnêtement c'est énormissime des
courses à autant le joueur vous est pris
dans un truc vous êtes la hat ha non
parce que oui vous qui est un petit peu
en inde je sais pas c'est aussi si je
vous dis on peut faire des dégâts
évidemment c'est la particularité de ce
beat for spring et les tec d'un son très
très amusant mais voilà comme je le dis
je trouve qu'on ait fait un peu trop
facilement donc la course commence vous
êtes à fond dedans s'est défoncé vous
allez vous essayer de gérer vos
dérapages vos billets étaient tous
pareils le premier voudrait tuer c'est
juste énorme c'est juste et puis et la
sensation de vitesse est vraiment
présent dans le jeu les couleurs sont
ville sont jolies honnêtement j'ai
surkiffé honnêtement si on n'aime pas un
jeu que qu'on est invité à tester je
peux vous dire que si on n'aime pas les
choses on peut dire honnêtement que très
bien hier par exemple je vous ai dit que
je suis dégoûté qu'on puisse pas
personnaliser l'apparence de la voiture
et qu'il n'y a pas d'histoire dans cette
force plus vraiment les deux points qui
me font chier mais je me dis d'un côté
il ya quand même 40 voitures
et on peut quand même personnaliser les
performances en fonction de la course
qu'on fait si c'est en pleine ville s'il
faut aller vite et ne pourra l'être
super vite si c'est un truc ou faut
plutôt faire des gains ont changé les
paramètres de la voiture nous devrons la
cool on va dire de sorte à ce que les
rennais qui ont une voiture bien mot
bien massif une voiture un peu et est
donc voilà donc ce mode multijoueur ya
aussi d'autres épreuves bien évidemment
donc une fois que vous aurez fini la
course
un nouveau point de rendez-vous va être
donné donc sur ses marques et sur le gps
tout le monde va y retrouva va pas y
aller parfois de très loin et puis vous
aurez nouvelles épreuves qui commencent
donc ces épreuves ça peut être vraiment
mais vraiment du n'importe quoi par
exemple une course complètement débile
ou c'est un grand huit là vous voyez à
l'écran
donc en fait c'est juste un grand huit
c'est à dire que la course vous fait 1,8
pendant tout le truc et les cours sont
constitués de checkpoint un job il doit
préciser il faut passer absolument dans
sinon vous êtes baiser dont vous ne
pouvez pas prendre un autre chemin qui
va a passé toute la course
faut passer dans des checkpoints pour
que ce soit confirmée et si dans une psy
vous envelopper 1 et vous vous en rendez
compte un peu trop tard comme ça nous
est tous arrivé lorsque on a testé le
jeu vous devez faire demi tour à m
ce pôle check point d'ancrage et l'a
donc ses costumes de 49 checkpoint et
c'est un grand vide dont vous faites
juste un grand vide donc c'est que des
dérives dans le garage ou une droite
puis du golfe à droite une droite ou de
la gauche et n'importe quoi et puis vous
avez d'autres modes de jeu comme par
exemple ce mode de jeu là qui est
particulièrement débile ou il faut juste
se garer en haut d'un truc est resté le
plus longtemps possible
alors honnêtement au début on a eu un
petit peu de mal à comprendre qu'on
n'est pas trop de vue du jeu genre owada
floch
pourquoi c'est ça mais honnêtement c'est
vraiment drôle surtout quand vous êtes
beaucoup et bien d'autres modes de jeu
comme évidemment le mode quête d'un
milliard mono faut sauter au dessus des
voitures alliez vous faites en négation
et le but c'est de sauter plus de poids
au dessus des voitures alliés il ya un
autre où il faut juste faire un saut le
plus long possible prenez vraiment pas
mal de modes de jeu et qu'ils sont mais
alors mais terriblement fun vous avez
aussi des courses en équipe donc là
c'est un peu la guerre j'en avais
quelques annonces et cardié tu sors de
mon équipe c'est des bonnes grosses
barres à faire et puis on peut aussi bas
juste vous balader dans la ville à deux
ça peut être drôle essayer de trouver
les greens qu'il faut casser ça c'était
dans burnout paradise est une espèce de
gris qu'il fallait casser ou alors les
panneaux dans lesquels fallait foncer
dans les phares speedboat nos contenus
explicites et dans un tube je crois que
c'était burns
enfin bref dans tous les cas voilà il
vous pouvez dans tous les cas et c'est
trouver toutes ces green is great pardon
et panneaux dans la ville avec votre ami
homo d'exploration si vous n'avez pas
envie de faire des prêts avant les
épreuves à mon avis nous fait un bout
vous invitez six potes vous faites ainsi
que le des preuves bien dure pas bien
bien du répit revient comme le saut
resté stationné un endroit ou quoi et
y'a de quoi franchement bien rigoler ou
pour se défouler hommes étaient le lot
et garonne et nous quelqu'un isabelle
schweiger
enfin bon voilà ses pénates france line
the spotted j'ai dit un peu l'essentiel
du jeu ce qui à nouveau ce qui a pas
trop nouveau mon impression j'ai juste
surkiffé les gens si juste énorme même
si j'ai ces deux fameux regret il n'y a
pas eu d'histoire et ont peu passionné
l'apparence de la voiture sinon ça reste
un mythe for speed j'ai pas eu
l'impression que c'était bâclé alors je
m'attendais un jeu complètement batlik
utiliser le nom du premier de france
puis qui avait très bien marché pour que
tout le monde achète on se disant ouais
ça fait de la balle alors ça aurait été
mieux mais c'est pas le cas des
innovations du lourd franchement j'ai
vraiment kiffé et je vous invite je sais
pas si on a mis des mots sur une démo je
vous invite à la tester en tout cas où
bat tout simplement regardé pas mal de
vidéos et eut décidé vous à l'acheter si
ça vous tente du jeu de voiture pour
ceux qui ne jouent pas beaucoup jeu de
voiture je sais que les fans de forza ou
quoi mais net for speed a son style à
part c'est un vraiment
ensemble quel côté de brno depuis on
sent qu'elle comptait naissance fidh
bref j'ai kiffé tout simplement
c'est un bon jeu à jouer entre potes
pour se marrer ou tout seul pour [ __ ]
et puis voilà en tout cas j'espère que
cette petite vidéo ne vous aura plu je
vous invite à mettre un petit gêne un
petit commentaire ça vous a plu et on se
retrouve bientôt bomba lorsqu'on sera
invité à a- et waïli surtout quoi pour
tester un jeu je vous en dirais mon avis
est en tout cas ce n'est qu'ensuite j'ai
surkiffé les gens bien plus que j'ai
quitté medal of honor bon j'avais bien
aimé une offre énorme monstre où il n'y
a pas de grosses innovations alors que
là un bon vieux jeu de voiture qui
revient et qui déchire ça fait plaisir
surtout qu'ils ont favorisé le mode de
jeu entre potes pour se taper des
sénardes là à bientôt tout le monde
pis aller
allez jeter un oeil
ct
je ne sais quoi